the whole country should be profoundly
grateful for the patriotism and courage
of its staff they work indophatically
every day to keep the British people
safe
since the start of 2017 MI5 and the
police have disrupted 37 late-stage
attacks
The Madam Deputy speaker
and islamist suicide bomber murdered 22
people and injured over a thousand
as well as inflicting incalculable
psychological damage and misery
I know that the whole house will join me
in expressing our profound sorrow and
extending our heartfelt condolences to
everyone affected by this barbaric Act
they were supposed to have a brilliant
time and come home safely
what should have been a simple pleasure
turned into a hellish nightmare
it's vital that we understand what
happened and what lessons we need to
learn
because we must do everything possible
to prevent a repeat of this outrage
volume 3 of the inquiry was published
last Thursday I want to thank Sir John
Saunders and his team who spent more
than three years on it
Sir John finds that there was a failure
by the security service to act swiftly
enough and problems with the sharing of
information between the security service
and counter-terrorism policing
following the publication of the report
the director general of MI5 and the head
of counter-terrorism policing offered
their profound apologies
for not preventing the attack
Sir John does not blame any of the
educational establishments that the
bomber attended for failing to identify
that he was a risk but he does find that
more needs to be done to ensure that
education providers share relevant
information about students
so John concludes that the bomber should
have been subject to prevent referral at
some point in 2015 or 2016 adding that
however it is very hard to say what
would have happened if he had been
approached under prevent or the Channel
program
the police investigation into the attack
operation mantlein is praised
although Sir John cannot conclude
whether the attack that the attack would
have been prevented he finds that there
was a significant missed opportunity to
take further investigative action that
he judges might have led to information
which could have prevented it
while this is welcome and the home
office will work at PACE with both
organizations to act on the Chairman's
recommendations we must not lose sight
of the fact that responsibility for the
attack lies with the bomber and his
brother
so these conclusions require careful
consideration Madam Deputy speaker
since 2017 the government has made a
number of changes to how we deal with
and seek to prevent terrorist attacks
we have given law enforcement and
intelligence agencies in
we have strengthened the controls around
access to explosives precursors
we've strengthened the management of
terrorist and terrorist risk offenders
in prison and on license
We've Ended the automatic early release
of terrorist offenders in England Wales
and Scotland
and we've ensured that the sentences
served by terrorists reflect the
severity of their offending
and we've strengthened the tools for
monitoring dangerous people in the
community
we've invested heavily in
counterterrorism unveiling a new
counter-terrorism operations center in
2021 that brings together Partners from
counter-terrorism policing the
intelligence agencies the criminal
justice system and other government
agencies
this will allow minute-by-minute
collaboration between teams and the
police and the MI5 and MI5
last year's integration of special
Branch into the national CT policing
network will improve our response to the
full range of National Security threats
boost skills and ensure better
communication between agencies and a
more consistent and effective national
response
work is currently underway to develop a
new Faith security training scheme to
raise security awareness amongst Faith
communities and help them to mitigate
threats
we continue to engage with faith
organizations and Security Experts to
develop this scheme
in April my writing will friend the
member for Whitton
announced the continuation of the Jewish
Community protective security grant for
2022 in May new funding was allocated to
provide protective security at mosques
and Muslim faith schools
in response to any terrorist attack
affecting British Nationals in the UK or
overseas the home officers victims of
terrorism unit Works to ensure all the
right support is available to them the
unit is conducting an internal review to
strengthen their work
I am overseeing a comprehensive review
of the contest strategy to combat
terrorism
this follows on from the Independent
review of prevent led by William
shawcross which assessed the program's
Effectiveness in stopping people from
becoming terrorists or supporting
terrorism
and as the independent review made clear
prevent requires major reform and I've
accepted all of the reviews
recommendations
it has underestimated the threat of
islamist extremism which Remains by far
the biggest that we face too often it
has minimized the role of ideology and
terrorism prevent will focus on security
not on political correctness and its
first objective will be to tackle the
ideological causes of terrorism
the government has also developed a
comprehensive system of support for the
owners and operators of public places
across the UK
this includes access to research driven
expertise through products delivered by
the National counter-terrorism Security
office and the center for protection of
national infrastructure
but we must go further Madam Deputy
speaker Martin's law formerly known as
the protect Duty will introduce
proportionate new security requirements
for certain public premises throughout
the UK
they will be better prepared ready to
respond and their staff will know what
to do in the event of a terrorist attack
Martin's law will clarify who is
responsible for security activity at the
premises in scope increasing
accountability
we are also considering how a full
inspection function will oversee
compliance to provide appropriate advice
and where necessary to sanction
Martin hett was one of those killed in
Manchester
I'm enormously grateful to his mother
Fegan Murray and the Martin laws
campaign team as well as to survivors
Against Terror and all security Partners
businesses Charities local authorities
and victims group
that have informed our work
I've always been humbled when I've met
them and heard about their experiences
the doctrines that underpin how the
Emergency Services respond to incidents
have improved since the attack
so Madam Deputy speaker I want to close
by once again recognizing the anguish
and courage
of the loved ones of those who were
killed or hurt on that Dreadful night
that United the country in sorrow and in
disgust
we will continue to work Non-Stop
prevent further such tragedies being
visited upon others and I commend this
statement to the house
Shadow Home Secretary Yvette Cooper
thank you madam Deputy speaker
on the 22nd of May 2017 thousands of
people including children and their
parents went to watch a pop concert
instead they were faced with the most
unimaginable horror and 22 people lost
their lives including children the
youngest being just eight years old
hundreds more were injured
those families have endured the
unimaginable and all our thoughts are
with them today and with the people of
Manchester who have stood and supported
each other through the most difficult of
times
I joined the Home Secretary in thanking
Sir John Saunders for this far-reaching
inquiry and his vital work seeking
answers for the victims and for their
families
the responsibility for this vile attack
lies with the bomber and his brother and
those who may have radicalized and
enabled them and we condemn all of us
their actions in the strongest possible
terms it is right that the brother has
been brought to Justice
but rightly too this report has looked
at why it happened what might have
prevented it to seek the truth for
families and their loved ones and to
identify changes needed for the future
and these are important and serious
conclusions that are hard to hear
that there was in Sir John's words a
significant missed opportunity to take
action that might have prevented the
attack that there was a failure swiftly
to act in on information
there were failures in sharing
information that the bomber should have
been referred to the prevent program in
2015 or 16 although Sir John says it's
unclear whether that would have led to
action but these are hard conclusions to
hear especially for those who have lost
loved ones
the Home Secretary has rightly said that
agency's encounter Terror police work
immensely hard to keep us safe every day
and so John also says in his report that
they have disrupted 27 major islamist
extremist Terror plots in recent years
in addition to five right and left-wing
Terror plots two and that is as a result
of their immense efforts night and day
and it is because they are dedicated to
keeping us safe they also recognize the
importance of facing up to things going
wrong and they've expressed their
profound sorrow and apologies too
so John has rightly made recommendations
and rightly everyone is seeking to take
those forward and we should support them
in doing so but I want to press the Home
Secretary just on some of the details of
those measures firstly on Martin's law
all of us support the work of fig and
Murray and many of the Manchester
survivors to introduce this can she tell
me the timetable will it have second
reading before the summer recess on the
closed recommendations
which clearly are important will that
entire report be shared with the
intelligence and security committee so
they can also oversee the changes that
need to be made
on the issues around prisons and also
around the prevent program the bomber
repeatedly visited a someone who was in
prison for terrorist offenses and that
did not trigger a further assessment
despite some of the wider things that
were known about the bomber and his
family that does raise serious concerns
will she look again at the process for
monitoring prison visits and will she
accept the recommendations made by Sir
John about the changes in approach to
visits to terrorist and extremist
prisoners that needs to be taken and
also his recommendations for changes to
the law
John also concludes it's highly likely
that the bomb has used a video online to
help make the device in 2016. it is
appalling that video was not taken down
it's also very troubling that seven
years on we don't have the Online safety
bill on the statute it also though
raises the concerns about the lack of a
proper strategy on online radicalization
so can I urge her to urgently revise the
countering extremism strategy which is
now eight years out of date despite her
having received or her predecessors
having received recommendations from the
countering extremism commissioner in
2018 that it was already out of date
then well she urgently revise it to
address online radicalization
so John also warns about the potential
indicator of extremism being violent
misogyny in this particular case and
there are patterns here affecting
different kinds of extremism islamist
extremists far-right extremist and incel
extremists so will she commission a
review into what role violent misogyny
may be playing and how far that should
be understood as a potential indicator
of extremism and radicalization so John
also raises Workforce pressures
particularly in the north west and given
the new threats from hostile states can
she comment on what resort her
assessment is of resources and finding
con case that the concerns were raised
that the security services did not
understand the threats from Libya its
sufficiently that that was a wake-up
call
will she recognize that shows the
importance for them to continually
reassess different threats and not to
have any hierarchy of threats or
extremism but to pursue the evidence
wherever it takes them the Home
Secretary raised the survivors and we
think of them many of them however are
still feel they lack the support and the
help that they need even so many years
after the terrible truly terrible things
that have happened will she meet with
survivors of Terror and will she look
again as well at what further support
can be provided for those who lost loved
ones and those who were hurt in that
terrible event as secretary
foreign
lady for her questions which I will
address in due course and I agree
entirely with her assessment
that we must now all come together the
government the security services and the
emergency services to learn the lessons
of this awful tragedy and work to reduce
the likelihood of future attacks it was
and it is a truly sad and terrible
incident but I want to assure that
reassure the public that our priority is
to keep them safe we must root out
extremism wherever we find it and give
no quarter to political correctness as
we do so we must respond quickly to all
criticisms but we must also recognize
the serious work that has taken place
since the attack so coming to some of
the questions that she raised in
relation to Martin's law the government
will publish draft legislation for
scrutiny in the spring and after that
introduce a bill to the house as soon as
parliamentary time allows its
progression after that is dependent on
the approval by Parliament and agreeing
a date for its commencement and there
will be a lead in time allowing for
those captured to prepare
Martin's law is one part of our
extensive efforts across government
including those of the police and
Security Services to combat the threat
of terrorism there remains an extensive
program of guidance in place which has
been developed by Security Experts
counter-terrorism policing and other
partners to provide stakeholders and
other those and others responsible for
public places with high quality advice
but I'm very much
looking forward to moving forward with
the solution and presenting the bill
relating to Martin's law when it comes
to prisons we have published a new
policy framework allowing greater
scrutiny around contact between
terrorist prisoners and the public our
new approved contact scheme to be
implemented this year will allow greater
checks on visitors and phone contacts on
those convicted of terrorist and
terrorists connected offenses regardless
of the category of prison in which they
are how
in relation to
further prevention
there is a large amount of work that's
been done since 2017 to support and
improve the consistency of local
Authority prevent delivery and to manage
the risks posed by subjects of Interest
that includes additional funding and
support for the highest priority areas
the publication for prevent Duty toolkit
and the development of the multi-agency
center program and we're working across
government to mitigate the risk posed by
those who about whom we have concern and
lastly she asked about support for
families going through this unimaginable
process and that's why I welcome the
Deputy Prime Minister's announcement
last week about the government's
commitment to legislate as soon as
possible to establish an independent
public Advocate to support victims
through a major or following a major
incident we that will that the IPA will
help victims to navigate the systems and
the processes that may follow a major
incident such as the police
investigations the inquests and the
inquiries I hope it's not used
ideally but in the event of a tragedy we
will have resources expertise and a
proper structure in place to support
families in this unimaginable situation
Deputy speaker I I know the whole house
will join me um we must move forward now
with the solution to ensure that our
Frameworks and our processes ours was
robust as possible so that we never see
anything like this again
charity intelligence and security
committee sir Julian Lewis thank you
madam Deputy speaker and on behalf of
the isci extend our deepest sympathy to
the families and individuals so
dreadfully affected by this terrorist
act I welcome the publication of the
third volume of the Manchester Arena
inquiry report and express strong
appreciation for the work of the inquiry
team of course the committee will
carefully consider the report and also
Sir John Saunders request that we should
monitor the implementation of the
inquiry's recommendations
in the meantime does the government
acknowledge and accept that the ISC is
the only Committee of parliament
equipped with both the facilities and
the clearances fully to undertake this
type of classified scrutiny
well volume
the chairman Sir John Saunders did make
it clear that he was determined that the
recommendations are monitored and he's
made arrangements with the ISC to that
effect volume 3 open has only just been
published and the volume 3 close
recommendations have not yet been shared
with the government the government will
carefully consider the reports findings
and recommendations in full
we will also consider any recommendation
that Sir John makes about the role of
the ISC and the role that it can play in
conjunction in light of the memorandum
of understanding that exists between the
committee and the government and that
mou is available on the committee's
website but yes effectively the ISC is a
very effective and secure Forum in which
as we as as has happened in the past uh
delivery on the back of these inquiries
can be properly scrutinized
SNP spokesperson Mari black here here
thank you madam Davis because
um the awful events on the 22nd of May
2017 led to the deaths of 22 innocent
people and hundreds more being injured
and affected for the rest of their lives
now of course ultimate responsibility
does lie with the bomber who detonated
his homemade device in the Foy of
Manchester Arena as the clouds left and
Ariana Grande concert now I welcome the
fact that MI5 have reflected and
apologized for their role in failing to
prevent this heinous attack for example
the report finds that intelligence could
have led to the bomber being followed to
a car where he stoled his explosives the
inquiry also found that two pieces of
information about the bomber assessed by
the security service as not being
terrorism related an officer also
admitted that they considered a possible
National Security concern on one of
those pieces of information but did not
immediately discuss it with colleagues
and did not write up a report on the
same day so firstly can I ask the Home
Secretary what steps she's taking to
ensure that the security services
improve in their Communications and
their information sharing as well as
guaranteeing Professional Standards
don't fall short as they have done in
this case and secondly the inquiry has
found that the bomber probably was
assisted by someone in Libya but because
of gaps and available evidence this line
of inquiry hasn't been addressed
sufficiently so can the Home Secretary
also provide further information whether
the investigation will continue to
search for who assisted the bomber and
given how much frustration the victims
families are understandably experiencing
from withheld information due to the
National Security implications can the
Home Secretary at least provide
reassurance to those families that the
UK government will leave no stone
unturned when it comes to getting
Justice for their relatives here here
I Thank The Honorable lady for her
question and following the attacks in
2017 MI5 and counterterrorism policing
together carried out a series of reviews
there are 126 recommendations included
better data exploitation wider sharing
of intelligence and changes to how
terrorist threats were assessed and
investigated an independent review by
David Anderson concluded in December
that concluded in at that point that the
recommendations taken as a whole will
strengthen MI5 and the police in their
ability to stop most terrorist attacks
so there has been a wide range of
measures and actions that have been
taken since 2017 to improve data sharing
and data exploitation and assessment of
intelligence but you know let me give
her and the British people this
assurance there is no stone that will be
left under touched before by this
government to keep the British people
safe that's why we have announced an
investment of 370 million pounds into a
new counter-terrorism operations center
seatock that is a new headquarters for
london-based counter-terrorism policing
intelligence community and government
partners and it will increase strength
resilience and collaboration of our
wholesale UK counter-terrorism effort
Mary Robinson
Kiana I'm grateful to my right honorable
friend for this statement today with uh
22 people murdered and over a thousand
people injured the impact on this of
this on families will go on for a
lifetime however not only must we learn
lessons but we must make sure it never
happens again I welcome the um the
government backing for Martin's law this
is really important because people want
to know that when they go into a venue
they are safe whilst we're waiting for
this to come forward and I hope it can
be brought forward quickly would my
honorable friend tell me what
conversation she's having instructions
she's giving to venues to make sure that
they start to act now and not to wait
until the the um legislation is put in
place
right to
um to to to mention and refer to the
steps that we are taking and that's why
we are going to introduce uh Martin's
law that will impose legal duties on
public venues and those responsible for
public spaces to secure them against
potential terrorist threats
um we we are already taking considerable
action to ensure that there is a advice
best practice and support for those
responsible for public places with high
quality advice being provided to them
many businesses and organizations
already do excellent work to improve
their security and preparedness but
legislative requirements uh we'll just
go that step further in ensuring that
there's a robust approach and that
everyone knows what their duties are
thank the speaker for allowing me to
speak as a contingency MP from the back
benches today
the Manchester Arena attack led to the
devastating loss of 22 innocent lives
including Allison Howe and Lisa Lees who
were killed as they waited for their 15
year old daughters from the concert I
went to place our record my heartfelt
sorrow to the family and also reflect on
their courage and dignity over the last
nearly six years during the course of
this investigation report can I ask the
Home Secretary from her perspective and
given now how long uh victims have been
waiting to see this report on the
outcome
the cruel findings of that report have
to be acknowledging she's done some of
that but can she go further and put on
record what will be done for the victims
to finally put right the wrongs that
have been identified in the report
well can I may I associate myself with
the comments that The Honorable
gentleman who's so powerfully made about
his constituents
um
the report doesn't pull its punches and
so John is unequivocal in uh his
assessment of what happened what should
have happened could have happened and
what may have resulted
um as a consequence
um it that is why
um the director general of MI5 and the
lead at counterterrorism producing uh
didn't shy away from their their words
that they expressed last week
it's absolutely right that we support
the families going forward I want them
to know that I have full confidence in
the process that Sir John has just run I
think it's been extensive it's taken a
long time some of the hearings had to be
carried out during covert with
additional burden the process was
exhaustive and robust at all times I
think we've got here an authoritative
conclusion and assessment of what
happened and importantly lessons that we
can all learn and take forward so it
doesn't happen again
uh Sir John Hayes thank you madam Deputy
speaker the Home Secretary is to be
commended for our statement today and
for her refocusing or prevent on his
islamist uh fundamentalism that tyranny
is uh the greatest threat to us but will
she take account of the recommendations
of this inquiry in two particular
respects the first the relationship
between counter-terrorism police and the
television Services she spoken about
collaboration meant to go and secondly
as the shadow Home Secretary said the
continuing observation of those who are
formerly subjects of interest but then
move to less stringent surveillance that
does seem to me to be a critical element
in this inquiry
well it's
under John said in his report no one
should underestimate the very difficult
job that the security service and
counter-terrorism policing do and that
job has become more difficult with the
emergence of loan actor terrorists
whose activities are more difficult to
track
and that's why the government including
MI5 is committed to doing everything in
its power to strengthen our defenses
against terrorism and that's why prevent
remains a vital tool for early
intervention without uh without a
prevent referral being made it is
impossible for authorities to intervene
to support those susceptible to
radicalization it is an important I
deserve an essential tool in minimizing
and eliminating the threat posed by
terrorism and it's vital that we now
carry out the reforms made by William
shawcross and improve it so that we
stamp out this Insidious Behavior
Jonathan Reynolds
if you speak I'm also grateful for your
special dispensation to speak from the
back benches on this matter the arena
bomb is one of the most distressing and
difficult episodes in the history of
Greater Manchester I think because so
many children have been affected with
life-changing injuries having been at a
music venue in the case of one of my
constituents who has been left without
her hearing possibly for the rest of her
life and my constituents have never
wanted this inquiry to be about blame
but about being able to say that we will
learn lessons that the response to the
country makes in future will be better
and stronger as a result of that and if
I could just raise two specific matters
the
um report does highlight the lack of the
update to the counter extremism strategy
now the Home Secretary mentioned many
things I think which form the strands of
that but fundamentally what I want to
know is if somebody who has links to a
country like Libya is visiting a non
tour offender in prison that will be
more closely monitored in future than it
was in the past and secondly from the
point of view of the survivors and the
victims families who I think have shown
great courage throughout this very
difficult process and like this
specifically pay tribute to things like
the Manchester survivors choir which has
been a huge source of support to some of
my constituents can the Home Secretary
confirm how they will be supported going
forward so now the inquiry itself has
finished
wait a second
well um he asked about the
um changes to the counter-terrorism
system and in particular
um the refresh of our world leading
counter-terrorism strategy contest that
has been updated to protect the public
from new and emerging threats to our way
of life and as I said we expect to
publish the updated version of contests
later this year we want to ensure that
contests achieves its aim of reducing
the risk to the UK from terrorism so
that people can go about their lives
freely and with confidence it's based on
prevent pursue protect and prepare and
we need to ensure that it is fit for
purpose so that the public are kept safe
from terrorism in terms of support for
the families there is a uh they have
been uh they have been heroic frankly in
the uh ordeal the they have been through
in voicing uh their uh their concerns
and their evidence and dealing with the
tragedy of of this uh horrendous
incident they have been very powerful
their evidence
has informed the recommendations and the
conclusions which will inform the
practice of MI5 and all of our security
agencies for that I'm grateful
James Daly thank you very much indeed
Madam Deputy speaker Olivia Olivia
Campbell Hardy was 15 years of age when
she went out that she's from Berry she
went out that evening and didn't come
back and she was a beautiful wonderful
person
um today we have the third volume of the
report
where it says there was a significant
missed opportunity to take action on the
heart but on part of ni5
we also have highlighted previously
shocking failures of the venues owners
the security contractors and the
Emergency Services
some of these people could still be
alive today not all of them
and I would like to know about
accountability too often in this place
an apology from an organization seems to
be enough well it's not people died as a
result of the actions not only of this
bomber but of the um gross
um
negligence of some of the the bodies
that I've been talking about who has
been held accountable who is going to be
responsible and will this information be
passed on to the families yeah yeah
well as the inquiries report makes clear
the responsibility for the events of the
22nd of May 2017
lie with the bomber and his brother
responsibility rests with them
when it comes to whether lives could
have been saved
the government is of course incredibly
sorry and sorry
it is a is is a weak word I understand
that for the the people directly
affected our thoughts remain with them
but miss
Sir John Saunders is also clear that
in his conclusion it remains quite
impossible to say whether any different
or additional action taken by the
authorities could have prevented the
attack it might have done it might not
have done
it's very hard to say what would have
happened if the bomber had been
approached under prevent all the Channel
program
it is it is difficult to make those
clear
directional direct causal connections
however as I've said before he doesn't
shy away from saying that there was a
significant oversight and there were
failings in the process
there are no words that will provide
Solace to the families affected but I
hope that they can gain confidence by
knowing that there is a huge amount of
uh seriousness being a attached to this
report and we are doing everything in
our power to make sure that the Lessons
Learned will be applied in the real
world
the thoughts now with the families of
the victims and can I thanks to John for
his report uh I hope so we'll be aware
that in 2018 the ISC which I sit on did
a report into the Manchester and the
other terrorist attacks that took place
in
2017 many of the conclusions are
actually mirrored in Sir John's report
one including the issue around the
purchase of pre-cursor chemicals Five
Years on still nothing has been done
about that the Home Secretary said to
the chair of the ISC that she respects
the work of the committee and it is
important that because we are the only
committee that can look at that close
report and closed evidence that those
recommendations if we make
recommendations are act upon to date
though I've got to say the government's
response to the work the ISE is not good
we're still waiting last July we
produced our right-wing terrorism report
the mou says they have 60 days to reply
to we're still waiting to reply to that
and can I just say to this the actions
of her Department in terms of our
scrutiny of the National Security bill
was far from helpful
has a second
well in terms of chemical precursors
about which he asked we've enhanced our
capabilities to detect terrorist
activity involving chemical biological
radiological nuclear and explosive
materials and their precursors and to
control and Safeguard those materials
and since 2017 amongst other things
we've strengthened the controls around
access to explosive precursors we
regulated sulfuric acid for example in
2018 and in 2023 we have laid a
secondary legislation which will improve
how suspicious activity reports are made
so there is a lot of work that we've
done in relation to that issue but of
course we can always go further
Mark Pritchard
UK has some of the best intelligence
agencies in the world and I have many
successes every day many of the
successes as homosexual know cannot be
made public but they also make mistakes
they admit it themselves as in this case
and indeed in other cases as well
so more widely but not linked to this
specific inquiry at this point is it not
time for the Justice uh the intelligence
uh forgive me the justice and Security
Act 2013 and the memorandum of
understanding which allows the
intelligence and security committee to
do its work should be updated in order
that there can be full comprehensive
up-to-date scrutiny of our intelligence
agencies which have huge budgets huge
powers and a huge personnel
but we do have do have very high level
of scrutiny over our agencies whether
it's the intelligence security committee
whether it is the uh the independent
reviewer and there have been in relation
to the Manchester Arena attack several
reports hundreds of recommendations many
of which have already been implemented
by the agency so there is a high level
of scrutiny we need to balance that
with the need not to tie the hands of
our agents as well because they do very
important very vital work and we don't
want to start chilling the effect of
their work
Mary Wilson thank you madam Deputy
speaker the Manchester Arena bombing was
an
utterly despicable attack on innocent
children and adults and our sympathies
go to all those families who are
affected and Madam Deputy speaker Sir
John Saunders report recognized failings
in information sharing the fact that
Salman abedi was a person of interest
would not have been known to many of
those who were perhaps best placed to
spot his radicalization and they were
unaware of the risk he presented
including at the mosque where he
worshiped so the Home Secretary
mentioned in her statement the new Faith
security training scheme could she
expand a little bit more on how that
scheme might appropriately equip
religious institutions and Community
groups to assist the authorities in
identifying potentially radicalized
individuals so they can help thwart
future attacks
website well there are lots of measures
that we have implemented and are
continuing to roll out to ensure that
those who are who may pose a risk are
receive some kind of intervention
um the ACT early campaign for example
seeks to raise awareness of the signs of
radicalization and where to go if you
need support about someone you know
we've we've had several reports about
educational is that sorry the shore
cross report looked into educational
establishments and how they can more
effectively support the work of
counter-terrorism there is a
multi-agency job of work here to do and
everyone needs to be clear about their
responsibilities to ensure that we
prevent and minimize the risk
Aaron Bell thank you madam Deputy
speaker could I thank the Home Secretary
for a statement and of course all our
thoughts are with the victims their
families and the survivors as well
prevents original principles were about
rooting out extremism and stopping
people turning into terrorists as the
shore cost review found that a number of
their projects drifted away from that
does my honorable friend not agree that
what has happened not only underlines
the need for successful and effective
prevent program that deals with the
people most at risk of becoming
terrorists whatever their motivation
my honorable friend is absolutely right
whether we're talking about islamist
extremism or far-right uh extremism the
review is clear the shore cross review
is clear that we need a more transparent
efficient and sustainable program uh we
need more independent oversight we need
to build uh our an extensive program of
communications and Community engagement
we need new risk assessment tools and we
need to ensure that there is a
consistent approach applied to all of
these risks so that we can be effective
in minimizing uh the threat
Amesbury
Deputy speaker Elaine MacKay
was a serving police officer for
Cheshire police who went along to a
concert like 22 of the people the
youngest victim
um being BNA and a very close family
member that worked in the immediate
aftermath of that terrorist atrocity
what I'm seeking from the Home Secretary
today and all those across the houses
reassurance that those recommendations
of the Sir John
report will be implemented in full no
ifs and no Bulls
well we want to ensure that all of the
recommendations of Sir John's reports
are are fully reflected upon and make a
difference that's what I'm focused on
that we learn we learn the lessons from
this tragic incident and we improve our
operational responses and our manner of
dealing with the risks we want to make
sure also that victims of terrorism
receive the support that they deserve
and that's why the victims of terrorism
unit is conducting an internal review to
see how we can improve the package of
support available to victims in this
terrible situation
Liam Curry and Chloe Rutherford from
South Shields were murdered in the
Manchester Arena attack the Home
Secretary will have seen their Brave
parents in reports outside of Court last
week
she will also know that archaic law in
relation to Terror attacks is denying
them the chance to register their
precious children's deaths
after being told repeatedly there was a
willingness from government to try and
change this law the very recently
attended another meeting with ministers
where this time they were treated with
contempt they were patronized and they
were insulted
it then became clear they have been
misled by the government for nearly a
year
because despite it being entirely
possible to change this law the
government and in particular her
Department simply do not want to
this is adding to their anguish and pain
will she please reconsider and meet with
them
well of course I deeply feel for and
sympathize with the families who have
been so tragically bereaved by the
Manchester Arena attack and and any
family bereaved in unexpected and tragic
circumstances to deserve our full
support and condolences
there is no legal flexibility
on this requirement as the death would
not otherwise be registered in
accordance with the legislation so I
know that this is a disappointing
situation this is not an issue that the
ministry of Justice alone can resolve
and the home office Minister Lord Murray
of Bloodworth explained to the
Manchester Arena families that long-term
change would interfere with the
coherence of the general register
officers registration process I know
that's disappointing but always willing
to consider new approaches
I'm Leah Griffith
details opportunity to tragically Miss
by MI5 but also reminds us of the need
for soul to be vigilance we know that a
member of the public who saw the
perpetrator and thought he looked
suspicious raised his concerns with a
member of the show sex security staff
but no effective action was taken so
whilst welcoming the government's
approach to Martin's law can I ask the
executive State what more the government
is proposing to do to ensure that
security staff in both public and
private sector have proper training and
well-rehearsed procedures of how to
respond in similar circumstances to help
to prevent future such tragedies
well I I thank her for raising uh the
proposed Martin's law
um the the details have been generally
uh set out premises that will be within
the scope uh will be those uh which uh
are uh defined uh an event or a premises
within a defined boundary that needs to
be a qualifying activity at the location
and the maximum occupancy of the
premises needs to meet a specific
threshold either a hundred plus or 800
plus there will be uh this potentially
will cover a lot of public spaces and it
will be a real step change in how we
ensure that there is more protection for
users of public spaces
speaker after the horrific tragic
cowardly Manchester Arena bombing
survivors and the victims families have
indeed shown immense strength and
courage throughout the whole inquiry
process however the victims and and
survivors of previous disasters include
including the Hillsborough tragedy have
had to wait years and years for
governments to act upon the
recommendations of reports and issue a
full response so can the Home Secretary
commit today to ensure that the
Manchester families do not have to
suffer a similar delay
well we are working out as I said
already there has been a huge amount of
change reform and Improvement within uh
the agencies as a response of the event
in 2017. uh this report marks another
step forward we will consider everything
and we will move forward accordingly but
we will also be responding to both
Bishop James Jones's report on the
experiences of the Hillsborough families
and the report of the Daniel Morgan
independent panel which will consider
the full duty of Candor and that
recommendation fully
for the compassion and the tone of the
Secretary of State's uh response I think
we all deeply appreciate it and think
that suggested for that on behalf of my
party at Democratic Universe party I
wish also to record Madam Deputy speaker
uh our our thoughts and prayers with all
those who lost loved ones and who today
grave greatly
will the studies get accepted the
parents of those children slaughtered
and me and are not looking for apologies
but instead are looking for improvements
to ensure that no parent goes through
the devastation that they have felt and
still failing and for those parents and
those families what further changes will
stem from the finalization of this
report thank you so much same section
well he puts it very well and
um just as a a sample really even before
this report was published since 2017 uh
MI5 and other partners conducted a
series of reviews subject to robust
external oversight and the intelligent
security committee published a report
there were a hundreds hundreds of
recommendations many of them have been
implemented already to improve the
counter-terrorism operations to improve
intelligence sharing to build a better
response going Beyond traditional
security agencies to connect expertise
in all different kinds of public sector
authorities so there has been a lot of
work which is on which has been
delivered and we want to build on that
I thank the Home Secretary for her
statement and before we come to the next
statement I would like to point out that
British sign language interpretation of
proceedings are available to watch on
Parliament alive dot TV
statement Minister minister